just over three minutes gone no shots on goal so
both teams being responsible defensively there's
the first shot Hinson fights off that good
defensive play is a recipe for success and
both these teams want to improve that I know the
Devils we' talked about I think they're capable
it's just a concerted effort and everybody pulling
for each other helping each other out here's Alex
De Brink it sends it down low open Net score and
it's Patrick Kane again his third in the last two
nights and he freezes vanich and the rest of the
Devils to shoot the pucker pass it to Kane Who's
down low from a sharp angle but nobody takes
that middle of the ice away and vanich has
to play the shot there for sure and nobody's
aware of Patrick Kane that's an easy one for
him here comes Teo Meer to the offensive end
for the Devils Meer sends it to mle out and it
is saved by Hutchinson and the Devils come close
to tying this up here's team o mys the Redwing
defenseman goes down he's mate Bastion trying to
shuffle it out Bastion scored a couple of games
too for the Devils hul it to the front oh Holtz
has it knocked away good play by Robbie F from
behind play hard play your game and Bryce kind
of mentioned it there where everybody kind of
gets caught in between and Kane's back door
Lazar puts it on and it is blocked Away by
Hutchinson at 25 in the league on the kill start
with Marino and Smith defensively here's it Blast
from cess be save B rebound is knocked wide by
Patrick Kane Kane Lin to Brink that Comer and
gos despare the five on the ice for Detroit
Comer couldn't hul that pass in but it rolls
down to Kane again doess bear moves it he gets
it back he fakes to Brink it takes it the circle
go Fair blast is deflected high and wide by Lin
Daniel spr it's strong down the half wall Sean
ther pins him against the boards comes up high
Siders loose he moves it and Van comes across to
Stone pan really changes momentum within each
game and in return the Devils have to pick up
the pace and get some momentum from those since
he's pass the nine game Mark Shon neit now game
number 11 that means his ELC an entry level
contract officially starts this year go for
the next three years there's no slide like there
was last season here's Dawson Mercer back hand to
the front McLoud whacking at it Meer finds him
he scores team o time comes early today backto
back games with the goal well we talked about
team o my anything can happen in Jersey again
it's McLoud going hard to the net and he takes
some Red Wings with him Hutcherson's on his back
and there's team oh my to clean it up right in
the slot to tie this hockey game up up Dawson
Mercer nice job just get that backand toward the
net with McLoud going hard your partners change
or it's a new guy you're with after playing with
somebody for so long Andre plot with good Puck
skills against cop his pass came out through the
slot nobody home you know sometimes when you're
playing with defenseman maybe it's your first or
second or third game with them right it's when you
watch him it's his Tendencies over the course of
yes we need to get back to our game put together
a more consistent effort but we hear the booth
we know how disappointed everyone is but we are
right there within Striking Distance again rless
on the puck he's strong on his stick and you know
he wants it that's half the battle big hit fire
throws a hit mer a turning burn and it's saved
Away by Hutchinson Devils will have to regroup
It Center they've out shot Detroit 105 in this
first period Heir a backand through Lazar puts it
on and Hutchinson keeps it out like Kevin playing
assertive and when he made that little rush in
the Detroit Zone Zone made his decision quickly no
hesitation down low helping the defenseman out
was McLoud and he skated it out Andre palot works
it to the Blue Line Jonas Sean thler bounces
it through and it's kicked Away by hutkins he
wants to see more compete in those battles to
draw penalties it's been a it's been a factor
you're absolutely right not as many power plays
and the Devils really feed off their power play
or we saw certainly early in the season where
it was deadly and it can really change momentum
as well and win you hockey games which it did
when the Devils even weren't at their best they
won some games strictly C of their power play
to Brink at blast this one in on Van tracting
from the outside moving that perimeter Tighter
and Tighter toward goal as Luke Hughes blasts
and Hutchinson makes the save 5 seconds left on
the power play Meer gets it Meer centers good
deflection HS and Hutchinson's laying on top of it
rebound was there Split Second little bit bit of
a late whistle and Devils keep digging away look
at that play by Meyer three shots on that first
power play for the Devils did not Score first
unit is out once again off a heer Faceoff wi
Luke Hughes drives it's blocker Away by Hutchinson
well you can see a little better angles and Puck
bouncing a little bit well Dan you just see oh
good save by Van on a daylight today top unit is
rotated out for New Jersey Jack Hughes hammers it
in it takes a live back to Brown he cuts in front
Hutchinson the save and Meer couldn't jab the
rebound home Jack Hugh set play as Brad skates
into this Bank off the boards and then shat just
kind of steamrolls him one more look at it there's
the good opportunity and I kind of jumped out
him Detroit's lost seven of nine the Devils 02
and one in their last three both teams looking
for momentum before the three-day Christmas
pause hard drive from wrong Puck Springs to Gess
bear and he burns it in bouncing Puck found his
tape and Shane Gess bear hammers it I mean it has
to be executed Marino gets it a little too far to
team o my and ends up being a turnover about
10 seconds prior to the goal in the neutral
zone where if that's tape to tape or Teo was
able to crowl that pass I'd have to look at it
again Dawson Mercer's on it Mercer and McLoud with
assists on the team o Meer goal back in the first
period Meer to the front score Michael McLoud
Taps it in this line comes through again tie
game around the blue paint and team Omar having
a strong game and starting to to find it a little
bit his confidence again he's got a goal now he
sets up Michael McLoud for The Equalizer just get
it to the net where's McLoud I'm not sure I'm not
sure McLoud touched it there I think that's going
to be team o Myer second goal of the game well
looking at it again I thought initially McLoud
tipped it but he does cause a little chaos W back
to the Blue Line H step speeds one time nitz is
turned away rebound browny shoots Hutchinson
kicks it out sharp angle Hutchinson stops to Poley
power play some opportunities there's the chance
from brat kicked out by huton as you see the big
youngst Devil's out shooting Detroit 3119 they've
tied the game on a Teo Meer goal his second
tonight here's jaser Brown he shoots deflected
score and the devil's lead Tyler to fly makes it
3-2 going to the net and the hay veteran gets
a little piece of this shot and I like the fact
that the lils just get it toward the net
and you see in the high slot as tley one
more look at it as brat spins away bides some
time and just looks like it went off the pad
of tooi one more look I want to see if it
was a stick or pad no he got the stick on
it cider moves it down low he gets it back 29
seconds left on the power play Fab backand the
slot that hit the post and pan missed an
open net rle it over the net let's watch
watch bam right off the pipe and then Lin
has the or pan has the rebound right on his
stick who missed yeah it was sprong
who with the post on the first one
right here one more look oh wow Raymond
with three puts it in his pocket and
the devil's come from 21 down to win 32
at home a crucial Victory here in 2023